hello everyone I'm Alana and welcome to
my channel today I'm doing something
that I am very excited about the RSPCA
which is a foundation for the welfare of
animals in Australia I reached out to me
and asked if I would consider finding
some adoptable pets and then making them
in the sims for cats and dogs so
naturally I said hell yes the first
stuff that we're starting with is choppa
an adoptable Labrador mix who is
available in the Los Angeles area so
we're gonna start by looking for
[Music]
Labradors Labrador Charita all right
here we go that's a base coat chopper is
a black dog what else can I do
I think shop is probably kind of chunky
that seems right to me
I'm sorry chocolate but it's mostly the
fluff though that's it's a real
disadvantage when it comes to fluffy
dogs that they just look fat but they're
not and it's not their own fault oh my
god he's 16 you guys chopper is 16 fine
chopper a home is here that's not gonna
do it first this boy has much more Lea's
and they don't like that that's a little
bit okay I think that one and then we
just make them short that looks pretty
good to me yeah head shape is correct I
think nose is indeed black he's maybe a
leg is slightly bigger nose pretty big
snoot on the upper paint mode we do need
to add in some little whiskers
he's got a little wipe it's around here
just lots of weight already
I don't know why he's going up to his
eyes that's weird it's just right on his
chin just like if we had
this I think that'll do it um okay he
also seems to have a little white bit
when it's tummy
I think what's coming like that I think
and then he's got some brown in him
which is gonna be tough because it's not
super brown it's gonna be super opaque
just like it's dang already how we did
it yeah I think that looks right
actually just like it's a break
you know he's browning cute you guys I
didn't I just notice it he has a little
white spot above his nose too so that's
looking pretty good to me there's only
two photos of chocolate the elderly dog
um who for the record couldn't be more
sweet and mellow he's not super active
so be happy with just a few walks today
and you'll be lucky to spend the rest of
his life with him I agree actually as
soon as I saw his listing I was like
holy [ __ ] I wanted I want to buy this
stuff immediately I would haven't been
good at I swear oh yes oh no wow I've
created a monster I feel like that's
close I know what he looks like but he's
just not right
like can I make you less poofy
oh yeah now you're just enormous like
he's not that big this dog is not that
big well I feel like that probably suits
the amount of fluff that he has but his
face just looks all wrong he's got he's
got a big-ish head but it's not you know
look at this oh I'm sorry about you a
huge head buddy but I feel like this is
pretty close to what he looks like
okay now we have to pick his personality
traits definitely gonna be friendly uh
number two he's gonna be lazy kind of
sleepy because he's like a nice old man
number three
based on the description I think he's
probably pretty loyal so let's give him
that
all right here we go hello my name is
chopped up and he can have you lost name
if you might want to adopt him okay
moving on pump number two he's going to
be Zeus Zeus is a black and tan Doberman
approximately one year old who is in
London or outside of London which is my
number one city for the people who were
following me Zeus had full worms in his
first year of life which sucks
I should typo on this page that says
Zeus has loved with a male dog before
however we do feel that it would be best
if he went to a home as an only dog
which made me think that he was gay but
you know I don't mind you need to type
in Doberman alright the photo of Zeus
kind of sucks if I'm being honest but he
is a lot more Brown than he is black
says it's no way to me to change that so
we're just gonna have to put in work
they actually might be more like the
other yes yeah more like this I think
it's definitely got bigger eyes not like
that it's still just kind of that shape
these looks so awful
no you know that these are right okay
well can I do that shape but not make
him cross-eyed it there we go okay a
little bit smaller it's mostly pretty
good yeah okay his face shapes looking
and looking good actually
I can't see his body which makes it
tough but okay we have snow you know we
have a lot of paint work to do on Jung
[ __ ] lead diamond puppy
so he's mostly a kind of like ong color
I'm just gonna move my camera over a
little bit she's like this kind of color
I think and he's got a lot of it maybe
we can make it a little more opaque it's
like oh well what am i a couple much of
his face with it to start with and then
we can kind of work back from that this
is where the image of Zeus cuts off so I
don't know what he looks like beyond
this egg that pot these pots are really
light he's good I guess some shading go
on yeah okay
Zeus looks much cuter in real life than
he knows in this Sims remake all right
well what's going on here what did I do
I'm sorry buddy thank you okay
beam that out all righty this is
available for adoption just outside of
London at the South Ridge Animal Center
ha ha cost later each pot is Bob en 6 3
el 7 legitimately that's a real place in
England someone called Potter's fire
this is very shy first and he needs to
be gently introduced to new people but
once he knows he was the most
affectionate dog and why my name is it
Zeus so he's a little bit shot is that
an option no well they said he ends up
being very friendly so we can put that
in there don't think that's necessarily
right um
he's he's either affectionate or clingy
it says he will cry he's left alone a
lot of puppies do that for the record
so we'll put him as loud he can be a bit
bulky when he sees dogs that dogs but
only through lack of confidence oh he
sounds so sweet ok it says he is bouncy
strong and can be a little bit jumpy on
the lead again anyone thinking that
about abducting adopting Zeus these are
all regular puppy things don't judge him
for that he's just being a pup so here
we have Zeus don't
number 3 is from my country of origin
Australia we are making putty from melon
putty is a bull Arab y'all don't have
bull Arabs know that one on a bull
terrier well our business training breed
so that is a tough one
show me your face friend oh that's a
terrifying face you have well we'll make
it work
well well fix that up that's gonna have
to go more are those cute though Cesar
actually pre-spawn first of all this
don't need to be white
just like make you completely white all
right changing a face again but it's not
terrible um much slimmer face though the
the mouth is similar here my dad
actually had a bolero
mmm I think it's gonna be it's gonna be
this one okay good enough
all right now party's gonna real cute
face but also for the record I'm saying
party PE Oh Dee why that's how it's uh
it's felt which I also think it's very
cute and was one of the reasons that I
chose Bodie
cuz it I thought it was a great name for
a dog obviously if you had ducked putty
you could change the name but she's also
got some more spots on the other side
it's why they just like kind of cups
this year but not not the whole thing
like that I think what's more because
there's a couple of dots back here
there's one dot right here
Oh your nose is way too short
oh no look at that way too short
well all of these look bad oh that
doesn't look right at all okay I need to
change your face shape I'm sorry it's
better this is like the same one it's
the Labrador but I think that's a lot
closer yeah just it's not this round
it is no way too big all right that
looks out and I may be better
questionably better this is really hard
for the record quite difficult I need to
I need to move that nose back so bad
that was not what this dog will look
like in person but you guys I tried at
parties name in here party is one years
old a lodge white and black female she's
also a little shy to start with as much
of them all she'd love to go to a quiet
huh easy to care for some not hairy
probably independent seems like a good
one for that like to keep in shape so
active is that a playful brotherly
what's that one
kids are a little overwhelming so that's
probably I guess we could go with
troublemaker
again probably not right because none of
these quite fit but you get the idea
alrighty you guys I hope you enjoyed
watching this video I'll leave links
below to where you can find these dogs
if any of you watching this are looking
to adopt a pet again we have party the
bull era in Victoria Australia we have
Zeus who is available in the UK and we
have my personal favorite chopper who's
available in Los Angeles I hope all of
these pups go to a good home and if you
guys enjoy this video
huge thanks to everyone whose names are
on the screen right now also I'm aware
this is not the right setup for a green
screen I doing my best when I get a
chair life will be easier but until then
this is how it looks
don't happy alright thank you guys so
much for watching I will see y'all next
time
bye